you know As Leaders wanted to think
leaders hate doing but they need to do
is what give constructive criticism you
know why we don't like even constructive
criticism because every time you do that
somebody walks may not liking you no
matter how you do it today we're going
to talk about how to do properly now
Patrick may be your host of I eat a meal
weekly and today we're going to talk
about how to give constructive criticism
and let me tell you something if you are
somebody that has any plans of doing
something big but you have a struggle
about giving feedback or you have you
struggle with giving people proper
direction on how they could improve
you're not really going to develop a lot
of strong leaders by the way in a very
open environment where a team is open to
giving each other constructive criticism
that environment typically grows as long
as they know how to go about doing it so
you can use this video and share it with
your teammates or other people to learn
how to give constructive criticism to
other people so let me walk through it
with you it's a simple eight step
process on how to do it step number one
is you schedule the time you meet with
them when you do you talk about their
gifts you talk about how much you
believe in them you talk about how much
value that brought to your organization
how much you believe in their
capabilities step number one is sitting
down and talking about their gifts their
beliefs all of those kinds of things
step number two you talk about your own
mistakes that you've made I think a lot
of times we forget the mistakes we've
made as leaders I think we need to spend
a lot more time talking about our own
mistakes a good parent talks about his
mistakes her mistakes to relate with
their kids a good leader talks about
their mistakes a lot more than their
successes your team is gonna talk plenty
about your successes you need to spend
more time talking about your failures
and the things you did wrong so number
two is you got to sit down and say look
I believe in you let me tell you I'm
about to talk to you about this but let
me give you some mistakes I remember
when I was this I made this mistakes
that number two is talking about your
own mistakes number three you ask
permission to be derived you know they
do I have your permission to be direct
with you do I have your permission to be
honest with you can I be very direct
with you and they'll normally
yes and if they say no schedule another
time to talk to them and be direct with
them but remember you got to ask
permission can I be direct with you step
number four address the issue so bring
up the issue John here's what I want to
talk to you about today this is what
happened XYZ can you tell me why it took
place the way it did and he'll explain
it to you here's what happened and give
them an opportunity for them to explain
why they do whatever it could be
why is your numbers the way you've been
why was it the way you spoke to that
person why have you been showing up
consistently late why is it that you
have the attitude you've had the last
couple weeks you don't you typically
have their positive attitude what's been
going on with you that we don't know
about is everything okay
then they'll explain it to you and you
know the more questions you ask when
you're wanting to address the issue the
more feedback they're gonna give you so
once they give that and you go through
the issue whatever may be and you get to
the problem what the problem may be
while I'm coming in later I'm not
working hard enough I'm not reading
books or I'm not doing this then it's
your job as a leader step number five is
to give proper direction to them you got
a given proper direction that parts on
the leader you've got to give them
proper direction many times you may say
well I want you to watch this video and
learn from this and give me feedback on
what you got from this video I want you
to read this article and tell me what
you got out of the article I want you to
read this 40 pages out of this book and
tell me why you got out of it I want you
to listen to this recording I want you
to finish this entire book and tell me
what you got out of the book and you
give them direction on how they can
improve in that many times cases like
this peoples of hati hati how do you
give somebody Direction well the more
book you read the more value you bring
here the more value goes out because you
can I just represent that book you need
to read this I know the story of this
you need to read that well number 5 is
you got to give them proper direction
point number 6 is selling them now
you're supposed to sell them on what
could happen if they correct this you
need you sell them on what can happen if
you make adjustments in your attitude if
you make adjustments in your work
schedule if you make adjustments in the
way you're dealing with people if you
make adjustments on your sales skills if
you make adjustments on the way you know
your work ethic is whatever it is you
sell them if you work on this you could
have this because they need to be told
they a lot of time this is belief
going back into it again and believe
going back into it again and that goes
naturally into step number seven so you
sell them on what could happen to
possibilities if you work on this this
is what could happen number sentiment is
poor belief talk about their gift talk
about their god-given talents talk about
your mistakes and how you improved in it
and number eight is now you must hold
them accountable meaning so when you're
gonna can you read the book by Friday
and get back to me yes Friday by five
o'clock I want to report great I want
you to watch this video by Thursday can
you watch it by Thursday and get back to
me with an email I want three paragraphs
on what you got out of it yes I want you
to listen to this thing and I want you
and I to have a one-on-one meeting
together and I'm gonna call you and I
we're gonna roleplay you're gonna tell
me how you got this than I did perfect
we're gonna do that you all them
accountable on what they need to be
doing to improve that specific area that
you are not happy with or police with
and if you approach constructive
criticism like that
you will see there's gonna be always a
little bit of friction on your team if
there isn't you're not really calling
enough people out but there'll be
friction but the friction is normally
going like this right friction is going
like this and everybody's elevating if
you don't everybody stays here and a
leader who's willing to put their ego
aside and realize at times some people
are not gonna follow like you for you to
be won't have the tough conversations
raise this the entire level of
leadership because he's willing to have
those conversations with the people as
long as you learn and improve your
approach with people and be extremely
sensitive for everybody because one
thing I know is everybody in a life is
going through things and when they are
going through things that doesn't mean
you don't address issues that just means
your approach has got to be strong it's
my message of the week Jim please be
sure to go on my website
www.themanufacturingmentor.com
[Music]
you